woody how are you this morning I'm feel
great yeah how are you I'm doing okay
what's the weather forecast how are we
looking for tonight's game three i
think--for october baseball it's going
to be beautiful I think we're going to
be pushing 70 degrees tonight so it's
going to be it's going to be great the
winds going to be blowing out probably
25 to 30 miles an hour it should be some
fireworks how did you did you pitch
differently when you looked at the
conditions if the wind was blowing in or
blowing out at Wrigley the only thing I
did differently it was the first usually
the first two months of the season where
the winds just howling in and it's
freezing cold I threw more fast balls I
dis challenge guys down the middle of
plate you can get away with that the
first couple months i'm outside of that
I mean Wrigley's when it warms up that's
always blowing out so it's definitely
it's definitely two different ballparks
when the teeth when the season changes
but you know tonight the winds shifted
last night and there's they're going to
be blowing out tonight and tomorrow
night so yeah you better keep the ball
down did you ever have one of those days
when you threw a pitch and somebody
almost accidentally hit it out you're
like what the hell is going on here yeah
we have those objects she was we're
talking last night Michael meant and and
fryer in town for that for the games as
well and we were talking last night
Mattie Clemente at a game when he was
here that I remember a shortstop going
pop pop up in the infield look like high
pop-up the shortstop goes out a little
bit and land in the basket how tough is
that though when you you just realize
that you can't doing about the elements
there yeah there's nothing you can do
and it's like you to see pray for rain
hopefully it is right now for the swore
ber decision your thoughts on the Cubs
deciding not to put him out there from a
fan standpoint obviously it would love
to see them line up from a from the
other standpoint I think it's the right
decision I think this is kids futures
too bright and to be taking that kind of
a chance with him you know you feel like
you take a chance anyway these already
out running the bases and if you has to
stop and go back and I think they're
more concerned from the side to side
lateral movements and they are forward
and backwards so or stopping and going
so
what he looked he looked impressive you
just you just don't see a kid to anyone
take that much time off and come back
and see the ball the way he's been
seeing it so he's uh he's locked in if
you had a draft right now for the Cubs
let's put both teams together but I'm
gonna guess your first pick will be a
Chicago cub who would be your number one
pick to build a team around g-man it's
tough to not say schwarber O'Brien these
bats it's tough to not build around
these bats but with with what Hendricks
has done this year with the ball the
mound and I'm a big believer in pitching
and defense and that's a tough question
i think there's a lot of guys would seem
you could build around i think we've got
five or six and they're all about 24
years old so it's Sophie i don't know if
i could name just one guy i guess just
being a picture i would say i mean i
don't know he got obviously Arietta's
doing what he's done the last year and a
half two years and no I think you got I
ain't got a choice to pick from from the
cops I think he got four or five guys to
choose from are they better than Kluber
I don't know how old is kluever mclovin
would you check see how old Kluber is it
feels like he's a little bit older than
these guys 30 he's 30 yeah yeah all
right so you're not going to go that
that direction is hendricks going to be
thus I Young winner when I say what I
didn't get to see everybody on Staten
around a consistent basis when I watch
his kids bring training and you know I
spent a few weeks in the spring training
and came back and told somebody's I'm
like Andres is going to win 15 17 games
and you know surprise a lot of people
like Kyle Hendricks yes and what did he
win 16 a won 16 games and they had the
air a title for the season I mean I
don't think we expected the air I think
this kid just he knows what he's doing
he's not afraid of any situation has
changed its devastating he's just he's
like a little mini Maddux obviously he's
got a long way to go to to get that
recognition but he is he's definitely
professor out there he's Kerry Wood the
former Cubs pitcher joining a Stan
Patrick show what did you make of some
suggestions that Steve Bartman throw out
the first pitch at a game at Wrigley I
think it's a great idea next year yes if
you win yeah if you win absolutely
the pitch let him throw it out or or let
the galaxies almost catch the pitch the
first fifth let him throw it out or how
about Moises Alou Moises yeah they can
throw it out together holding hands
would prior catch the first pitch from
Bartman I don't know yeah I don't know
yeah I would say yes if you if the Cubs
won the World Series I would imagine
Moises Alou or mark Pryor would catch
that first pitch yes i would think i
would have to believe so you see I'd say
let's win it first and then we can
discuss that well my concern would be if
you had Bartman threw out the first
pitch now and you lose the game ya can't
take that chance nope nope nope you can
I was also talking up Paulie my
producers obsessed with Mark Grace and
the fact that he did what he did playing
all those day games at Wrigley I said
Gracie wasn't a big partier I mean he
would go out a little bit but he was
kind of lame you words out roommate for
a little while right he was a smart
partier it's a smart partier yeah see at
home and Wrigley when you have no day
games you just got you start earlier so
you got to finish earlier right the guys
that come over here from other teams and
they start partying like they do after a
normal game all of a sudden they've got
two or three extra hours on their belt
by the time they go to bed and those
guys don't make it through the season so
Gracie figured out how to party smart
why is sammy sosa estranged from the
Cubs I don't know I don't know I think
he was such a pivotal part of this this
organization in the history of this team
so I you know I pulled for him to try to
come back and and get it right near will
eventually they'll get it they'll get it
figured out i'm not sure what what the
holdup is but i think i think it'd be
great to see soon to be a part of all
this stuff who's throwing out the first
pitches I have no idea so they didn't
ask you I threw that last round I got
game six last round yeah you're not
World Series where your stuffs not
filthy enough for World Series no no I
think they say that stuff for the whole
thing guys so r I know right now I would
imagine Billy Williams I would imagine
Fergie probably come out I'll be great
yeah that'd be great I hope I don't see
Bartman Nelly you said that well they're
not they can't have him throw out the
first pitch no we're not
I would not hope so do you think
somebody's going to do an actual movie
that's based on Bartman not a
documentary but that we do a movie based
on Bartman I don't yeah I mean I don't
know they haven't done it yet I mean to
his credit listen he could have he could
have written a few books he could have
had a movie out he could have made a
bunch of money off this thing and he's
never he's never done one interview I've
reached out to him a couple times I know
dusty reached out to him I know what
some other players have tried to reach
out to him and he just stay away I don't
blind in the guy's life was ruined by
two seconds of his life at the decision
he made so I can't blame the guy but I
think they should let's win this thing
squash all the curses and and get these
people back involved the organization
because he was he was a it was a big
Cubs fan well what what were you going
to say to him if you got a hold of it I
just want to grab a beer and be like to
worry but I think this just yeah I just
want to sit down with him apologize hear
a story him to see what his wife's don't
like the last you know 12 15 years i
think it's been you know he had a rough
go it was a crazy crazy time for
everybody but his life was the one that
was changed not ours but you guys were
leading and it's Gonzalez makes an error
right after that I mean there were so
many other people to blame than this
poor guy down the absolutely but when
you're that hungry for a championship
and and you don't know when you're going
to get back there next and I don't know
I think just did that yeah no you just
did what every other fan did and we
would have all been the same do you
imagine though I always wonder about the
guy next to him because that guy was
about what a foot away from having his
life ruined if he says no get out of the
way I'm gonna go get this foul ball yeah
there was like six or seven other sets
of hands and everything okay and it just
turned out to be his I have fun tonight
are you going yeah yeah taking the
family so I have the kids there tonight
I'll good you know we could good to see
the first World Series w at Wrigley
Field in a long time do you buy tickets
or day gift tickets to you I bought
tickets did you really did I had a
gifted raped at a gifted rate oh yeah is
everything else rating of a month ago
trying to make sure I track these things
no what is that
gonna make sure I had tickets for that I
just want to make sure everything's okay
with you and the Cubs here would he be
you know yeah yeah we was going to still
have a decent relationship okay I would
screw that up have fun and great to talk
to you great talk to me all right it's
kerry wood the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience